as students get ready to return to the
classroom crossing guards are needed to
help with that process
hundreds of paid positions are available
and they're all over the valley too
christian casadas joining us now live
from our newsroom with more on the need
and also the requirements kristen that's
right denise wells there's definitely a
need more than 600 crossing guard
positions must be filled
according to the county today efforts to
meet that goal were launched
all around the valley now take a look
here on your screen i met up with the
hiring team at aloha shores park on
buffalo and cheyenne
organizers were there to hand out
basically any answers to people's
questions
and help them with the application
process 675 crossing guards are needed
to serve
at 430 intersections around the valley
which include north las vegas
las vegas and the unincorporated areas
of clark county
now 148 locations in henderson also are
in need
of crossing guards now if you're looking
for a job well this position pays 15
bucks an hour
retired people moms basically anybody
even if you're working a job you know
you can be an alternate and work on your
days off
you can call us and say hey i'm off
monday and tuesday this week or
i i want to be an alternate i only want
to fill in sometimes and
that'd be great giving back to your
community is always awesome
that's right well anyone can apply but
the ideal candidate is at least 18 years
of age or older they must pass
an agility and balance assessment hiring
teams will be fanned out across the
valley conducting
interviews and hiring candidates during
the next few
days now school hours as we know vary
across the valley but
normally it's an hour in the morning and
another hour in the afternoon to apply
just visit our website 8newsnow.com
christian casadas 8 news now